[SPEAKING CHINESE]
So I'm going to speak
English for our benefit.
So let me go back.
So my name is Brahim.
As Summer said, I'm a product
manager on the Play Store team.
I work on a couple of
things, but today I'm
going to talk to you about
commerce and monetization.
One of the reasons
why we're here
is to make sure that all of you,
developers based out of China,
can now be successful selling
your apps and goods globally.
One of the key services we
provide to you is payments.
It is collecting payments for
you from 130 plus countries,
and then remitting that
to you here in China,
so I'm going to talk
to you more about that
over the next few minutes.
So I couldn't help but
repeat this number.
Chris Yerga mentioned
this earlier,
and the fact that we
are where we are today
is incredibly exciting
to us as a team.
I started on the
team three years ago
when things were very
different, and having paid out
over $5 billion in that
one year time frame
is incredibly exciting.
And we think that with the help
of all of you here in China,
we will be even more successful
and we're just getting started.
So just another call out
for that number, which
for us is incredibly exciting.
So we think of payments
in terms of two
main chunks of activities.
One is you are building
all these applications.
These apps and
games are ultimately
driving a user to
make a purchase,
or obviously just
have fun, but I'm
a commerce guy so it's
about making a purchase.
And as you drive more
and more of your users
towards pressing that
Buy button, which
is incredibly difficult,
it is our responsibility
on Google's side to actually
convert as many of those users
as possible.
And so to do that,
we've done a ton of work
over the past couple years
I'm going to walk you through,
but I'm also going to walk
you through what things you
can do within your applications
to actually make sure
that users successfully
get to that step.
So there are two
chunks of activities.
There is you getting people
to press that Buy button,
and then there is us converting
more and more of those users
around the world.
This is a frame of reference.
So I'm going to start
off a bit to talk
about how an entrepreneur
and how a business starts.
Essentially, you're in a
market you're familiar with.
Let's not say that's Europe.
Let's say that's actually China.
And you're thinking of an idea.
You have a need.
You have an opportunity you
feel is really important.
And at some point,
you say, I'm going
to build an app that
fulfills that need.
And so you start
off with the market
you're most familiar with.
You may then jump to another
one that's somewhat close
and that is somewhat
familiar with you
that has a similar
need, and then you
expand to another market.
What's amazing is
all of a sudden,
you're a global business.
You're a global business.
In the past, this
used to be a big deal.
Companies used to
restructure when
they are a global business.
Companies used to hire
different kinds of people.
But one thing that's important
is for you, it happens so fast
and it's so seamless that
sometimes it kind of just
happens and you
operate the same way.
You don't actually change
the way you operate.
But it's actually
really important,
as you build these
global businesses on top
of Google Play,
which we believe is
an incredible global platform,
as you build these businesses,
that you think about it
as a global business.
You are all global
businesses, I guarantee it.
So that's another aspect, and
what's exciting to us is that
developers that earn most of
their revenue from abroad,
from outside their main
market, their home market,
they earn 2.5 times
compared to those who don't.
And so when you go global, when
you take this step to drive
most of your
revenue from abroad,
you're actually also
earning much more,
so keep that in mind.
Now, what's exciting
to us is this number.
Over the past year,
we've had 38% growth year
over year in developers
doing just that,
developers earning
most of their revenue
from outside their home market.
This is important for
us because, of course,
we believe Google Play is the
perfect global platform, being
incredibly objective, so when
more and more users and more
developers are taking
advantage of it in that way,
that makes us incredibly happy.
And I know you guys--
no, I'm kidding.
You don't want to make
us happy, it's fine.
So that's another point.
So starting off
talking about, what
are we doing on the Google
side to make you successful
globally?
First off is reach.
You can distribute your
apps in over 190 countries.
Today, with our
launch, literally you
can have users in
that many countries.
You can sell to users
in over 130 markets.
This is the point about you
being a global business.
You are going to have purchases
from 20, 30 plus markets.
That's a fact.
And finally, we
have 65 countries
where you can
tailor your pricing,
and as we'll talk about later,
that is actually particularly
important to your users.
So broad reach, global reach.
Again, the theme of you
are a global business.
Interestingly, as we
went out and started
building a payments
and commerce platform,
we realized that to actually
be a global platform,
you have to think very locally.
You have to think about each
user and their preferences
in each market.
We spent a lot of
time working on this.
So for example, in
the US, credit cards
are the way to buy.
They're essentially the
frictionless payment method.
In Asia, DCB and
Direct Carrier Billing,
which is when you place your
purchases on your carrier bill,
on your monthly phone bill,
is actually extremely popular.
So two markets, both
extremely large,
both extremely successful, that
use entirely different payment
methods.
China is no different.
And so as you think about
your markets and users
that you have in
those markets, you
have to think locally
in addition to that.
So over the past
year, we've actually
launched Google Play gift
cards in over 25 markets,
we've launched carrier
billing in over 28 markets,
and we've launched
PayPal in 19 markets.
All of these steps are,
again, to make sure
that as users in different
markets come to Google Play,
that we convert as many of
those users for you as possible.
So when a user presses the
Buy button, we convert as many
of those users as possible.
That's our mission, and with
these local forms of payment,
we're able to do that,
and I'll show you
a case study to that effect.
This is the launch of the Google
Play gift card in Germany,
and what happened in Germany
was super interesting.
There you go.
Since launch, year
over year, we've
had a 70% increase in buyers.
This is the number of
users that are actually
making purchases in Germany.
So step one, more
people are buying.
Step two is we've had a 25%
improvement in our conversion
rate, which means how many users
who click on that Buy button
actually complete that
purchase, and that's
important because you
don't care about people
pressing the Buy button.
You care about them
completing that purchase.
So we've had a 25%
increase year over year.
And what that led to is a 3x
increase in sales in Germany.
So this is a case study that
represents the way we think
about local forms of payment.
You enable a market, you give
it the right forms of payment,
you get more users
to become buyers,
they increase their engagement.
You then get better
conversion and ultimately
what you all probably
care about is the sales
are up significantly.
And so we hope to
replicate this elsewhere.
So in Hong Kong, we've had
an 80% increase in buyers
year over year.
Over that year, we've launched
carrier billing and gift cards.
In Russia, we had 100% increase
in buyers year over year,
again, launching
carrier billing.
And so as we launch
these forms of payment,
we're seeing that model
replicate-- increased
engagement, increased
conversion, increased sales.
That should probably not
say "starting today."
It's been awhile that we've
actually enabled this feature.
But essentially, payments
are about consistency.
What used to happen in the past
is that a user that actually
uses carrier
billing to purchase,
when they came to
their Wi-Fi tablet,
they could not use that
form of payment, which led
to just a broken experience.
So a few months ago
now, we've actually
enabled carrier billing
on Wi-Fi tablets.
And so if you activate your
carrier billing account
through your phone with your
SIM, that form of payment
would then be available
on your other devices,
including Wi-Fi devices.
This led to a really cool
improvement in the user
experience for
tablet users, which
is an extremely
important segment for us.
Also important to us, just like
what we're talking about today,
is enabling local content
and local apps to be created.
And so over the past
year, we've really
prioritized how many
countries from which
developers are able to sell
apps into the global market.
That's what we
did here in China,
and that's what we're
here to talk to you about.
And so we are at about 54,
and actually, the number
is probably 62 or
over 62 by now.
And so you can see us continuing
to push more and more markets
where developers can build local
content, because as all of you
probably know, it's all
about local content.
The more local content is
there, the more engagement users
you have, and from then on, the
monetization cycle can begin.
So really excited
about this number.
So now let's talk about what you
can do to improve monetization
within your apps.
First off is localizing
your listings.
If you are targeting a
market, you obviously
can't localize in every
language and every market.
We know you need to prioritize.
But if you're
targeting a market,
if you're serious
about a market,
you're investing ad spend,
you're actually acquiring users
there, you're doing
user acquisition.
If you're doing that, then you
need to localize your listing.
Dropping a user into an English
language or Korean language
listing when they're
coming from Indonesia
or Malaysia or any
other combination,
it just doesn't work.
And so what we've
seen, actually,
listings that are localized
convert 6x better than those
that aren't, and Pocket here
does a really good job at that.
Next is localizing
your pricing, and this
is one of those really
simple things that actually
cause a lot of trouble.
I always hear that local
developers have an edge over
those that aren't
local, that somehow,
the local developers know things
that the foreign developers
don't.
Where this is one of those
really simple things that local
developers get right that
foreign developers don't.
In Japan, 100 yen is the
right pricing format.
It is not 101 in this case.
And so while we have
this real easy to use
tool that automatically converts
your prices into all 65 country
currencies, you actually need
to go through and understand,
is that the right price?
What is the equivalent of
that magical number that
makes the purchase seem low cost
or makes it seem significant?
There are prices that, as we all
know, mean those kind of steps
in the user's mind, and
converting in a purchase flow,
any slightest thing can
give your users pause,
end up hurting your conversion.
So when you do your pricing,
think about the local market,
think about the local norms,
and adapt your prices to that.
So 101 yen should be 100 yen.
We did an analysis of prices
in Japan in particular,
and we saw apps that are priced
a little bit over and a little
bit less than 100 yen actually
converted 2x worse than those
that aren't.
So think about this.
This is important.
This is one of
those no brainers.
Please, you just
have to do this.
I think we've touched on
this a few times today,
but there are multiple
models for you.
A point I want to make here
is that your business model
may actually vary by market.
So different markets may have
different buying patterns.
In some, it's all about ads.
Maybe it's the only way
for users to pay, i.e.
they can't, and so you're
going to have ads primarily.
In other markets,
you may do in-app.
Subscriptions is more
of another dimension,
where certain types of apps
do best in subscription.
Others do really well in-in app.
And so there are multiple
dimensions to consider,
and the important
thing about this
is that you need to decide
at the very beginning
of your product iteration.
When you build your
product, it fundamentally
depends on what kind of business
model you're going to choose.
Is it going to be a feature
upgrade, and so that's
more of an in-app?
Is there recurring value
that you're creating,
in which case, it's more
of a subscriptions product,
paid app, ads, et cetera?
Subscription sales
on Google Play
have continued to grow
over the past year.
We're super excited
about it and we
believe that it's a really
good model for certain types
of apps, again.
And so again, as you
build your application
and as you design
it, think about
whether you are offering
recurring value for your users.
If you are, then you
should definitely
consider using Google
Play subscriptions.
We're building out the
platform to offer you
all the tools you
need to build a really
good experience for your users.
Now, another important aspect
is if you have recurring costs,
then you probably want
to have either an in-app
or a subscription experience
because a paid app model
obviously will not work out.
So we've launched a few
of these features already.
So for example, we already
have seasonal subscriptions
that could work for sports
type apps, content type apps.
We've launched your ability
to give goodwill credits,
and what that means is when
a user calls and they're not
happy about something that
your app has done to them,
unfortunately, you
can give them a credit
or you can refund them
a particular purchase.
So that, again, helps with
building user engagement
and retention.
We also offer you now APIs so
you can issue these refunds
from your back ends.
So if you have already
customer support tools,
you can plug into
our APIs and make
this completely seamless
for your support staff.
Upgrades and downgrades is a
feature we're working on now,
and we're going to be launching
that in the near term as well.
What that will
allow you to do is
allow you to upgrade a user
from one tier to the next.
So a lot of times, you have
an introductory tier where,
let's say it's a storage app.
You may have a 1.99 tier
for one terabyte of storage,
then you may have a 10
terabyte or 100 terabyte
storage tier for even more.
What we're going to
do with this feature
allows users to swap between
those plans very easily.
So within your app, you
can trigger an upgrade.
The user upgrades, they
get the right credits,
we do all of the
math in the back end,
and the user just
seamlessly changes plans.
Chris touched on this as well.
I cannot stress this enough.
It is incredibly,
incredibly important.
Building quality apps
is just the baseline
for being successful.
And these numbers, everybody
intuitively thinks and knows
that building a higher
quality app converts better
and does better for
you, but these numbers
are staggeringly high.
An app going from two to
three stars to four stars
has a 9x improvement in revenue.
Going from the four
range to five star
or getting close to
five, obviously, you
get another 4x
improvement in revenue.
So the ratings,
the stuff that Elie
talked about around replying
to reviews, fixing bugs,
QA, all of these things
actually impact your sales.
They actually help you
earn more from your app.
We know that a lot of you are
obviously resource constrained,
and so when you are
investing in resources,
you can either build
features or fix bugs.
We all have to deal with that.
And so this number,
what we're hoping
to do is give you some data
that can help you drive
that decision, give
you some information
that can help you
make those decisions
on a day to day basis.
But quality is
absolutely important.
This is another kind of
quality/basics type of thing.
Apps designed for tablets
monetize 10 times better than
those that aren't.
When you have someone
using a device,
they expect the app
to work well in it.
They expect it to be
designed for that device.
If you are not designed
for that device,
then don't target that
device, but if you
are trying to
acquire users, again,
tablet users or
specific device users,
then you have to build
an application that
works well and is
designed for that device.
This is really, really
important, especially
as we see more form factors
become available on Android.
Whether it's Auto, ATV,
Android TV, or Wear.
So Wear, you get
it almost for free,
but you should check whether
the basic experience works well.
Of course, you can build really,
really awesome experiences
when you tailor your app's
experience for that ecosystem,
but the baseline is make sure
that whatever device tier
you're targeting, that
it's designed for it
and it works well in it.
There's going to be more
and more of these things,
so you really need
to say ahead of it.
So to summarize, one of the
first things we talked about
is thinking beyond
your familiar markets.
Obviously, you are
going to be reaching out
to markets in 130
plus buying markets,
and so that gives
you lots of choices.
It gives you a lot of
countries you can target to.
It gives you a lot
of countries where
you can do user acquisition.
But be very mindful of what
countries you're targeting.
Be very purposeful.
When you reach a market, design
your app for that device.
Localize your listing.
Localize your pricing.
If you're acquiring
users in a market,
just be very
intentional about it.
Being easily global
on this platform
has that double edged sword of
one, you reach a billion users.
On the other side, you
reach a billion users,
and so you need to think about,
how will each of those users
interact with your
app, and make sure
that your experience is good.
That's the second point around
localize, localize, localize.
And finally, continue
to focus on quality.
We on Google Play are extremely,
extremely focused on quality
and make sure that
our users have
a great experience on Android.
And so success is directly tied
to you building great quality
apps.
This is especially true, again,
as the proliferation of devices
and Android TV and
Wear and Auto and all
these awesome new opportunities,
this is particularly true
that you need to be mindful
of the quality of your app
in each of those platforms.
That's all I had.
Thank you so much.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]